three months after the events of
operation greenstone every major
military force in the world has created
a blockade around aurora while their
politicians battle it out for the rights
to the technology it holds within
however a number of breaches have
occurred which has meant the ghosts had
to be covertly redeployed onto the
islands in order to assist the outcasts
the bodaks have been spotted throughout
aurora taking hold of various
territories while their goals and
purpose is currently unknown they have
managed to land a number of their
offices with varying degrees of
experience in different fields onto the
island
only time will tell but it seems to be
coming clearer with each passing day
that whatever it is is likely to affect
not just russia but the entire world
[Music]
[Music]
was formerly part of the russian army
where he specialized in ballistic
missile systems
in 2020 he resigned from the army and
chose to pursue a career where he could
profit off the extensive skill set that
he'd acquired over the years
he would end up becoming a consultant
working with a number of different
private security companies
his approach to his work is clinical
precise and cautious
he upholds a high standard of protocols
at all times and expects nothing less
than the best from those around him
while he was an avid ravens rock
sympathizer he preferred to distance
himself from their activities at the
time
however becoming a huge supporter of the
new bodak leader's plan he has since
been recruited
intel suggests that he's now on a rower
conducting a heavily classified
operation
costas schertkoff is a renowned hacker
best known for his work in industrial
espionage
he works in the private sector using
illegal and unethical methods of theft
to obtain business trade secrets which
his employers then use against the
competitors to gain an advantage
often he will target foreign companies
and go undercover with the express
purpose of spying and stealing
information
he is highly adept at not just stealing
sensitive data but also planting false
leads to frame individuals or
governments
while he has never worked for the
russian military in any official
capacity intel talks to his loyalty as
well as his ultra-nationalist ideologies
but such a man has a great number of
enemies so it's of no surprise that he
has a tendency towards extreme paranoia
with an immense distrust of others and
fear of being caught
because of this he takes great care in
covering his digital tracks
the only possible lead which is
currently unconfirmed is the name
chirtkoff which is likely an alias used
for his cyber operations
his last confirmed activities involved
hacking into the russian foreign
intelligence service to declassify the
case files and expose certain
interactions within the russian
leadership
vessel krapoken specializes in
disinformation and propaganda
he graduated from a highly esteemed
russian university
he then spent several years working for
media companies and misinformation
websites
before he was approached by the russian
government and offered immunity in
exchange for his help
he would be under full protection of the
government as long as he assisted with
furthering their agenda
he showed extreme proficiency in being
able to create and grow hatred against
those the government deemed as an enemy
convincing the population of the
justness of russia's regime and enlist
the act of support and cooperation of
others
this would then be followed by making
the enemy appear savage barbaric and
inhumane
but eventually he would lose the support
of the russian government
after he published propaganda that
embarrassed high-ranking officials
he has since been known to work closely
with russian ultra-nationalists
not because of his personal ideologies
being aligned with theirs
but because he is completely driven and
motivated by money
however he certainly does seem to get
some satisfaction from seeing the
results of the lies he spreads and the
chain of events that follows across the
world
katya maximova is a ruthless business
leader with a great deal of political
influence who aims to restore her former
standing within the upper levels of
russian society
after her father was accused of spying
for foreign countries and was in turn
labelled as a traitor she quickly lost
all of the support and public standing
she had spent years building
she had built herself into a position
within the russian government by
supplying illegal goods and dealing with
the covert firearms exchange
she never married in an attempt to
preserve the purity of her lineage and
family name
she is cold and morally vacant
while on the outside she can appear calm
and collected almost charming
she is highly manipulative
she doesn't care who she has to walk
over and stomp into the ground to get
what she wants
after the accusations against her father
she avoided her own trial and set forth
with a stash of funds that she used to
purchase the leadership of ultra
nationalist group raven's rock
now with her own private army she aims
to enact revenge on those who rejected
her
her plan is to commandeer the valuable
scale technology from aurora leaving a
bloody trail of war crimes that would
later be blamed on russia
name wealth
power
narcissistic self-entitled
she's a woman scorned and she'll do
anything she can to destroy those who
belittled her
understanding that a lot of people still
haven't played through and finished the
conquest mode i've deliberately
attempted to keep most of the spoilers
out
but also because of the many hours of
gameplay i recorded while running
through it the majority was corrupt and
unable to be used so this video was far
less detailed than i had planned it to
be but it is what it is
i'm going to play through it again and
capture everything that i missed because
well i actually enjoyed it however due
to my horrific schedule and my attempts
at keeping content released in a timely
fashion i'm going to reach out and ask a
favor
those of you willing to help i'm after
intel
while i have a lot i'm still missing
information on the events of motherland
a lot that i've managed to lose through
the issues with recording but i also
have a few holes in the collectible sets
i realize this could leave me bombarded
but if you have any information or
screenshots on the intel please send
them through to my email found in the
about section you'd be doing me a huge
solid
otherwise i'll just keep pushing forward
it may just take me a little longer to
recapture the information and then get
my ass into gear and write a script and
video
but thank you very much for watching i
hope you're enjoying the motherland
update and i'll catch you in the next
one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
you